LIKE THE ONE IN MILWAUKEE IS A
TOUGH LOSS, AND YOU DON'T THINK
THAT ANY GAME IS GOING TO BE
EASY AND IT IS NOT IN THE NBA,
BUT IF YOU COME WITH THE RIGHT
MINDSET TONIGHT AND READY TO
COMPETE AND UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
HEAT TEAM HAS BEEN PLAYING WELL,
THIS IS A GAME THAT YOU HAVE TO
WIN.
THEY HAVE THREE STARTERS OUT,
AND YOU ARE AT 13-18 COMING IN,
YOU HAVE GOT TO HAVE A CHANCE TO
WIN THIS AS UDONIS HASLEM KNOCKS
DOWN A THREE, AND NOW, LOOK, I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY YEARS SINCE
UDONIS HAS MADE A THREE, AND I
WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE HIS COACH
HIS ROOKIE YEAR, AND 2003 AND
2004 HE WAS A BIG PART OF THE
CHAMPIONSHIP TEAMS HERE, AND
FOUR FINALS TEAMS WHEN HE WAS
STILL PLAYING IN THE ROTATION,
BUT HE WAS NOT DOING THIS.
>> Kevin: NOT HITTING THE
THREES.
>> Stan: NOT EVEN AT THE BEST.
>> Kevin: HOW ABOUT THAT.
>> Stan: THAT IS A FUN INTO THE
EVENING FOR THE HEAT CROWD FOR
THE HEAT BENCH AND FOR UDONIS
HASLEM WHO IS ABSOLUTELY BELOVED
IN THIS CITY.
I MEAN, THINK ABOUT THIS, HOW
MANY TIMES HAVE YOU SEEN THIS IN
THE NBA OR IN ANY SPORT, AND
PLAYING HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL
HERE, AND WINNING TITLES, AND
THE GET AWAY TIME WAS THAT HE
WENT TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
FLORIDA AND TOOK THEM TO THE
FINAL FOUR IN GAINESVILLE AND
SPENT ONE YEAR IN EUROPE WHEN HE
WAS NOT DRAFTED AND HE GOT
HIMSELF IN GREAT SHAPE, AND NOW
IN THE 19th YEAR HERE AT 41
YEARS OLD, AND PHENOMENAL
CAREER, AND PHENOMENAL PERSON.
>> Kevin: HE JUST HIT THE FIRST
THREE